-Congratulations.
Six years is really amazing.
-It really is. What a treat.
-Your show did not just an
incredible job of, I feel like
reacting to what was happening
in Silicon Valley,
but often predicting what
would happen.
Like, here's, like,
you from the first episode
-Yeah, what can you say?
We have a bunch of, like,
clairvoyant Precogs
working at the show as writers
We have -- You know that scene
in "Minority Report"
where there's that weird entit
that spits out the carved balls?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's --
-You've got one of those.
-That's Mike Judge, yeah.
-Yeah. Oh, wow.
He just lays in, like,
a bath of milk?
-"It's coming!"
-You've been here before
saying that you wanted
"Silicon Valley" to end in the
universe of "Game of Thrones."
-Oh, yeah.
That would have been nice.
-Just, like, got all tied into
an HBO family.
-Yeah, and then I had
a sword and armor,
and everyone is like,
"He's the hero, it turns out
Oh. Okay."
-But now you have a new idea
-Yeah, yeah. Here's my pitch
Okay -- And there's no tim
to make this happen.
But we end up in the
"Big Little Lies" world,
and it turns out,
we killed Skarsgard's character.
-Oh, wow.
-It was us.
We are the little guys,
and we did it.
And everyone is like,
"Who did it?"
And we're like,
"It was us the whole time.
-Wow. So all those women
are innocent.
-They're totally innocent.
-Oh, my God.
They've been covering for you.
-Yes.
Time old --
A story as old as time.
♪♪ A tale as old as time ♪♪
-You -- I know you --
We met first --
-That's "Beauty and the Beast.
Which brings me to my question
-Oh, really?
-We met -- Well, we did.
We met as improvisers
in Chicago.
-Yep.
-But did you ever -- the way you
said "tale as old as time,
was the theater
ever a path for you?
-Yes, Seth.
I did cut my teeth
upon the boards.
-You did.
-Oh, yeah.
Community theater of
Nelson, British Columbia.
Boy, we know each other
very well.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. The stage.
-They're happy to see you again.
Yeah. "When are you going to
get back onstage?"
-Yeah. People must ask you
all the time.
-Oh, yeah.
It's a fun world, the theater.
It's a lot of, "Oh, oh!
I haven't seen you in ages."
It's a lot of that.
-Oh.
-It's like, "Oh, Tech Week."
"Oh!
Hands on your own props,
guys, seriously.
Seriously."
-So if you go back to
the theater,
you're going to fall right
back into it.
-Oh, yeah.
I'm going to be stage manager,
exclusively.
-Oh, that's --
Yeah, that'd be great.
You had another piece of wor
recently that -- very exciting
-I've been busy, man.
I've been doing
a lot of good stuff.
-Very. Not "Silicon Valley,"
not theater.
You entered the world of actin
in a video game.
-Yeah, yeah.
A lifelong dream of mine.
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-So, this is just
motion capture.
-Yeah.
That's what it looks like.
-And what was the game?
-Well, it's, you know,
a franchise
I'm super-well-acquainted with
It's the "NBA 2K" franchise.
-Okay, gotcha.
So now --
-Yeah, a big lifelong gamer.
Always wanted to be in
a video game.
And I got the call being,
"Hey, do you want to be
in the NBA game?"
And I was like,
"You know I don't know
even how to play basketbal
whatsoever."
-Don't worry. I don't play
I'm a sports agent.
-Wait. So, you got cast
in a video game --
-Yeah, to play a sports agent.
-And there you are
in the video game.
This is so disappointing.
-Yeah.
I'm just in a diner scene,
you know?
-Yeah. You're not even
in outer space or in a stadium
-No laser guns, no nothing
And I was like, "Oh, can you
do a little something?
You know, pop that jawline
a little bit more?"
"No, no.
We're going to make you look
pretty standard
Middleditch right there."
-It also looks like the scen
where the player
is firing you as his agent
-Yeah. There's a lot of things
and, you know, it's in
the story mode, right?
And you make decisions,
so there's a lot of scenes
where he had to do --
where we talk
and then we just enter thi
sort of static animation.
while this player has to,
like, make his decision.
-Oh, I see.
So I'm at home
waiting to press a button.
And what are you doing
while I'm waiting?
-And I'm like, "So,
Jay, what's it going to be?"
You just go to the sunken plac
for a little bit.
Yeah.
-You were someone --
When you were growing up,
were you on the Internet a lot
Were you --
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
-No, I feel --
As soon as I asked,
I was like, "Obviously --"
-Do you even have to?
Yeah, yeah.
I've been known to,
as a wee lad,
browse around the corners
of some chat rooms.
-Yeah, yeah.
What was your
chat-room life like?
-Oh, you know, just trying
you know, practicing flirting,
either with girls or peopl
who I thought were girls.
-Yeah. Do you feel like yo
picked up some skills?
-Uh, yeah, pal. Yeah.
I know how to talk to ladies
ASL, babe.
I need that age, sex, location
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-So, is that still -- And
you found that that transitioned
very well into the real world?
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I go up right to
someone's face and say, "ASL."
-Wow.
-Uh, 37, male, here.
-Yeah.
And then you're off and running.
-Yeah, like, "Ugh! Not for me.
Got to be way older.
I don't even see a fanny pack.
-Genuinely, congratulation
on six seasons.
It's an amazing accomplishment
Thank you for being back.
-It was a dream to do this show.
-It was great.
Thomas Middleditch, everybody.